we begin with the vaccination efforts
now the health district
is looking into expanding hours at local
clinics this comes after a weekend of
extremely long lines at the convention
center and the cashman center
reporter kate houston is live from the
convention center with how the lines are
looking like today kate
yes well thankfully right now
individuals are able to go in and out of
the convention center for their
afternoon appointments fairly quickly i
want to give you guys
a look here at what we're seeing really
not much of a line but it was different
this morning
i did speak to clark county chairwoman
marilyn kirkpatrick earlier today
she tells me they're pulling resources
to expand hours
at some of these clinics now the
convention center is one of the closest
vaccination sites to the strip
many hospitality workers ranging from
accountants to housekeepers were here
this morning to get their first dose
when the site opened there was a bit of
a line some waited over an hour nearly
an hour and a half
chairwoman kirkpatrick says they're
looking at expanding hours at some
clinics
to be open 12 to 14 hours a day
they would open early and close around 7
or 8 p.m
hospitality workers i spoke to say
expanding hours is vital to get more
people vaccinated
as the city continues to open up a lot
of people work at um
at night and then they came coming over
here you know like the swing shift
so that feels great right here the
convention center seems pretty good
we could use probably more clinics
further on the east side around the
boulder strip
there it gets neglected quite a bit
at this point clinics would not be open
24 hours a day
chairwoman kirkpatrick says they'll look
into that option
if they do need it now within the last
hour we learned that some individuals
received an email stating that their
vaccine appointment
at cashman center this sunday will need
to be
rescheduled the health district says
that this is
due to the fact that there will be no
vaccine event that day at cashman center
i have reached out to the health
district for more information
i am waiting to hear back i'll give you
an update as soon as i get it
reporting live from the convention
center tonight kate houston 8 news now